this is what happened to Anna after
happily ever after Princess Anna brings
a whole new meaning to the word courage
while she might not have any magical
powers of her own she'll do just about
anything to save the ones she loves
watch until the end to find out if Anna
ever develops powers of her own first
time with the things don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's find out
what Anna's been up to since her happily
ever after she gets married to Kristoff
some frozen fans would rather not see
Anna and Kristoff get married and frozen
too and while they might have their
reasons not everyone agrees with them
Disney has decided to omit weddings from
their latest films instead they've
chosen to focus on friendships and
family relationships this prevents the
younger generation from making
unrealistic assumptions about love and
prompts them to focus on finding
themselves well we couldn't agree more
we think that Anna and Kristoff are
simply perfect for each other so while
there might not be a royal wedding in
frozen 2 we expect there to be one in
the future despite not airing this
special event it's been confirmed by
Disney that Anna and Kristoff eventually
do get married however they don't rush
into things this time around do you
remember when Anna and Hans fell in love
if so you surely recall how they decided
to get hitched within an hour or so of
meeting one another you mean to tell me
you got engaged to someone you just met
that day yes
pay attention despite Elsa's warnings
Anna was ready to jump into a lifelong
commitment because she was under the
notion that true love conquered all well
reality hit the young princess like a
ton of bricks
especially since Hans turned out to be a
power-hungry lunatic so knowing this
Anna and Kristoff took their time to get
married and the weight paid off she has
a family have you ever wondered why
Disney Princesses don't usually have
children well we have and believe it or
not but Ariel is one of the few Disney
Princesses who has a child of her own as
a matter of fact princess melody even
got her own movie while we'd love to see
jasmine Snow White and valve
come mother's some of these characters
are simply too young in the past Disney
Princesses were made to be around 16
years old or younger and despite the
many years that have passed by they
haven't aged today this all changed when
movies like Moana brave and frozen came
out the newest princesses were older and
less focused on getting married and
having babies of their own regardless of
this babies do make the world go round
so with this in mind and we can only
expect that Anna and Kristoff will
eventually want to have kids anyone who
has played Sims for frozen four kids
knows that these two characters will
eventually have a family of their own
however those who haven't played this
videogame aren't in the loop while Anna
and Kristoff aren't in a rush to have a
family
they will allegedly have a boy and a
girl when the timing is right she moves
out of the castle Anna might be the
princess of arendelle but she'll never
be a queen and for the most part this
doesn't seem to bother her while she
loves her sister Elsa with all of her
heart there might come a day when she
wants to build a life of her own
sure Elsa is more than happy to share
her duties with her younger sister but
Anna might start to dream a different
dream although Elsa has shown little to
no interest in getting married or
relationships in general there might
come a day when she does meet someone
special and if the Queen gets married
and has kids of her own there will be
little left for Anna to do in arendelle
so Kristoff might enjoy living in the
castle he might also grow a little bored
of the same old cordial affairs so the
newlyweds could potentially decide to
relocate and start building the life
they've always dreamed of if you're
curious to find out just where Anna and
Kristoff will wind up stay tuned because
we'll reveal their new location at the
end of this video she gets kidnapped by
Hans when on and met Hans for the first
time she mistook him for the love of her
life while they appeared to be perfectly
in sync
Hans had other motives in mind as many
of you know Hans is the Prince of the
Southern Isles however he's 13th in line
for the throne while most people in his
situation would accept that they'll
never be king
Hans cooked up a plan of his own that
placed him on arendelle
throne after charming his way into
honest heart he conspired against her
family and plan to have Elsa killed but
sooner than later his plans unfold
before his eyes so much so the last time
we saw Hans Anna punched him in the face
so hard that he flew into the ocean so
while we'd love to believe that Hans let
bygones be bygones we expect that he'll
be back for round two and his comeback
might happen sooner than we think some
fins speculate that Hans will be a
returning character in frozen - but
believe it or not it said that Hans will
become Queen else's love interest which
is slightly absurd but hey people can
change rights she goes to college in
Corona while it might be hard to believe
princesses are also required to go to
college sure Queen Elsa might have
bigger fish to fry but honest still has
to come up with a life plan of some
sorts by now it's no secret that Anna is
a kind and nurturing person which is why
she might wish to become a veterinarian
this would surely make Kristoff happy
especially since he has a reindeer of
his own who might one day need tending
to to get the best education possible
however Anna might be required to leave
arendelle for a year or two she seemed
to follow her dreams Anna might moved to
Corona where she can live with her
cousin Rapunzel while she goes to
college despite wanting to go with her
Kristoff would have to stay behind to
take care of spend so with this in mind
the couple decides to partay
in a long-distance relationship but not
before getting engaged first I could I
mean I'd like to I may I we meet I mean
maybe she's bringing criminals to
justice
all honor ever wanted was to play with
her sister
sadly Elsa was forced to give her the
cold shoulder to prevent her from
getting hurt after tragically losing
their parents Elsa vowed to protect her
younger sister by staying as far away
from her as possible after all it was
her powers that nearly got her killed in
the first place after almost getting
fooled by Hans Honor received a newfound
appreciation for justice with this in
mind she set out to protect the people
of arendelle
into crime and malice this was no easy
feat however which is why Christoph
chose to join his girlfriend's ranks
together the couple solved crimes and
brought criminals to justice whenever
they could
sadly they were never able to locate
Hans again despite having attempted to
murder the queen of arendelle Hans was
allowed to sail away to the Southern
Isles and continue badgering people with
his evil plots this would never have
happened if arendelle had been equipped
with a proper law enforcement department
so wanting to keep the Queen and her
people safe on a set out to create
arendelle's first-ever police station
after forming the ultimate police force
on I felt much better about moving out
of arendelle and starting her life with
Kristoff although she still makes it a
point to visit her sister a few times a
year anna has her hands busy with a
newfound purpose so don't go anywhere
because we're going to reveal where Anna
and Kristoff moved in a few seconds I
like the open gates we are never closing
them again she finds out the truth about
her parents all Elsa and Anna ever
wanted was to see their parents again
but it looks like they'll have to settle
for their brother it's been stated that
Tarzan is none other than the prince of
arendelle and mom many Disney fans
marveled over the possibility of Henry
uniting with his family whether or not
this will happen in frozen to remains to
be unknown but for the sake of
imagination let's pretend that Tarzan's
somehow finds his way back to arendelle
after marrying Jane and moving to her
hometown
Tarzan sees a picture of his parents in
the local newspaper beneath it is a
paragraph stating that King Agner and
Queen a dunas daughter Elsa has just
been crowned as the queen of arendelle
stunned by the news he and Jane travel
north to arendelle to connect with his
long-lost family despite only having an
old picture of his parents as proof Elsa
and Anna welcomed him back with open
arms their baby brother's existence
confirms that their parents didn't
perish at sea but were instead
shipwrecked on an uncharted island we
don't know about you but we'd love to
see a family reunion take place in
frozen 2 however for this to happen
Tarzan and Jane would have
to be reimagined in the same animation
style that we see present and frozen
should this fan theory fail to come to
light in frozen - we're sure that Disney
will consider it for frozen three she
becomes mother Claus we all love
Kristoff he's funny sweet and caring are
you some sort of love expert
no but I have friends who are but most
of all he would do anything for Princess
Anna if you've been patiently waiting to
find out where Anna and Kristoff move to
after choosing to leave arendelle you're
in luck because we're about to spill the
beans so believe it or not but our two
love bugs are moving to the North Pole
where they will train to become father
and mother Claus if you're having a
little trouble accepting this
information listen carefully because
we're about to lay out the facts
first off Kristoff is the Scandinavian
version of the English name Christopher
which is Santa Clauses first name
secondly Kristoff rides a sleigh that is
pulled by a reindeer and let's face it
only one other man is known for doing
the same thirdly Kristoff was raised by
a group of trolls who could easily be
interpreted as elves so knowing all of
this is it too far-fetched to believe
that Anna will one day become mother
Claus to contribute to Christoph's
vision Anna will use her veterinarian
degree to take care of the countless
reindeers she will end up owning
together she and Kristoff will create
one of the best-known traditions the
world has ever encountered and they will
make sure to uphold it too while being
the princess of arendelle has a nice
ring to it
Anna will find her place in the world
and bring joy to millions of children
while some fans think that Kristoff will
become the first-ever Santa Claus others
believe that his actual dad is the
original father Christmas and instead of
getting left behind as a child Kristoff
accidentally fell off his father's
sleigh and was never found again so
after a long search the original Santa
Claus will locate Kristoff and urge him
to come back home and follow in his
footsteps she develops powers of her own
Queen Elsa's powers started to manifest
from a young age however her mom and dad
didn't have the slightest clue
where they came from while it's true
that their cousin Rapunzel
also has magical powers hers are the
result of a powerful flower however when
it comes to else's gifts nobody knows
where they came from or how they work
some fans believe that Ana will develop
powers of her own however they think
that hers will only start to manifest
come frozen - so if Elsa is the ice
queen what does that make Ana
well popular belief states that Ana will
develop fire powers and become known as
the fire princess although we'd love for
both of these sisters to have special
powers it's hard to believe that Ana's
magics would have taken so long to kick
in if there's one thing that's for sure
though it's that fire powers would come
in handy should Ana ever move to the
North Pole after all no one wants to
live in freezing winter conditions
forever so do you think Ana is going to
be given magical powers let us know in
the comments and that's a wrap
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]